[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about what
we want whatever we want to sell high
buy low no no no buy high sell low baby
damn right
so low
i don't actually know what we're going
to talk about i just mean either yeah i
just thought that was funny because
we talk about it when the cameras are
off so i just yelled it out well no uh
we're talking about the meme of uh the
dos equis guy
saying i don't know he's he's holding
the thing right and he's like i don't
always
but when i do it tips again guilty ass
charge
that's been our laugh of the day which
is why we uh named joe the trace echoes
guy
isn't that funny how it's like it
happens so much that it's a meme right
like when you sell
you're like [ __ ] yeah peak price and
then it goes even higher you're like
[ __ ]
or you buy haha and then it goes even
lower you're like mother
[ __ ] that's always gonna be you're
never gonna be like all with like the
all-time
highs when you sold it the like all-time
lows when you bought like that's a
[ __ ] luck man's game you know
yeah nobody gets that lucky right now
dude
insiders maybe insiders hell yeah the
wyckoff the wyckoff distribution guys
are having fun who the hell are those
guys
uh well the there's a pattern out there
that's like it's like um
it's basically the white cough pattern
has happened right now in real time on
the blockchain like in its like textbook
but basically this guy named wyckoff in
the early 1900s he wanted to prove that
the markets are so [ __ ] manipulated
against the common man
that he came up with a formula and he
has a chart
that basically shows exactly what just
happened in crypto and so a lot of
people right now are talking about that
about like it was manipulated it was
maybe
it was like but everyone thinks don't
say that so nonchalant explain to the
people how it was manipulated
yeah explain to them okay sure so so
what happened during the bear market
right bitcoin was being accumulated for
years
okay so all there's a large amount of
people out there with huge bags of
bitcoin and they can use that to
manipulate the market and will
they can literally make the market do
whatever the [ __ ] they want sick it's
pretty sick but
isn't there like only like three or four
miners out there that has like a
huge [ __ ] bag well china has one of
the hugest amounts i think they have
thirty percent supply or more right now
yeah and there's i mean there's a bunch
there's a bunch of different places but
the point is
is that there are heavy heavy heavy huge
hitters out there
who can manipulate the market at will
and they're trying to scare all the
retail people
um so that they can get cheaper bitcoin
the whole reason why i got into crypto
is so that i can
hopefully help uh people in our family
get houses and stuff and like switch
over to real estate
and then i'll start thinking about real
estate in terms of like bear and bull
market
and i'm like okay cool it's a bull
market in crypto right now it's
technically bull market and real estate
because the seller's market oh yeah and
then i'm like
so the smart thing to do would be if you
can cash out big
at the peak of bull market for crypto
and then buy real estate
in the bear market where it's at its
cheapest and then that got me thinking
i'm like is this what the ballers do
they just jump bull bear bull bear
across industries
they don't experience the bear yeah they
just bull bull ball ball ball and salsa
and just go on a big
big giant circle or they do what you
know
what jp morgan got caught doing where
they manipulate like the silver market
and does anybody even really know about
that i guarantee nobody in this room oh
no [ __ ]
i totally don't but that's how but so
what they do right they were
manipulating the silver market
okay for years and then they got caught
doing it
and what happened they had to spend they
had to pay a billion dollar fine
but that's it is jp morgan still in
business of course they are
is nothing of course not how were they
manipulating the silver market like i
said
when you have big bags you can control
the market if you if you have big enough
bags you can actually
at will like control the price you can
control
like the middle east controlling the oil
and stuff absolutely it's the exact same
thing what can i control
nothing so perfect
barbell supplements now i can't even
control that he won't even brag about
barbed will sophomores he says it's the
same generic [ __ ]
we do custom formulations i'm very proud
of them but the stuff inside and
everyone else can get it you actually
need to order some more barbell
supplements especially the pre-workout
oh you like it
oh we got a new flavor i want this lava
mango really
wait for mango guava mango oh i thought
you said flamingo i was like
well you guys were next level yeah our
guava mango new one oh
but what are you doing juice i'm super
down i don't know actually
this month though this month all right
barbell pre-workout's the best
it gets you like it feels like a drug
[ __ ] yeah i love it
dude that's why i [ __ ] love it i want
the sour gummy one can you give it to me
yeah thank you
i can't do pre-workout yeah you don't
need it i don't think it's the closest
thing to math baby
that [ __ ] is so good bro actually i'm
scared you should see nikki on uh
adderall that's closest thing to math
yeah adidas is like one component away
from method it's diet meth
diet diet matter yeah that's true
premium quality meth it's probably more
pure right low dosage meth didn't make
it no i mean
technically meth actually is pretty pure
in one way it's just like when you like
think about the stereotype of like meth
remember that adderall uh
[ __ ] documentary i was telling you
about on netflix that has barbell yeah
yeah yeah yeah they talk about it and
they show these
wait they have barbell in it yo it's
sick bro
i literally was just talking to this
dude about after all like the day prior
i was here jk news a couple weeks ago
and then i go home and i'm looking at
netflix and then there's this [ __ ]
adderall documentary
and i'm like oh we were just talking
about this so it was peaking my interest
is very
you know synergistic to my lifestyle
right now press play
maybe like 30 minutes in this like huge
football player who like got injured
starts
talking about a story then starts
talking about how he got onto adderall
afterwards his performance just started
peaking he was like his injuries weren't
a thing he was like able to get on the
court with focus and like do his thing
he wasn't hungry anymore and he's
working out
got lean and he's working out at barbell
brigade i see like the [ __ ] skull
thing in the back it's all
it's all blurry because you know depth
perception and camera [ __ ]
and i'm like this [ __ ] looks [ __ ]
familiar and i literally took a [ __ ]
screenshot i sent the bar i was like yo
this little shot at your [ __ ] gym ak
synergy again round two
that's true synergy and adderall energy
so wait
you knew they were gonna shoot there you
didn't do anything you didn't troll it
didn't do anything at all
no people shoot there all the time you
replace all the dumbbells with shake
weights
like knowing you you would do something
like that if you knew that that would be
pretty funny
not just people there's like a nike has
shot there
quest has shot there a bunch of things
have the nike one
i was really excited about because it's
like you know nike's one of the biggest
brands in the world they're gonna shoot
there
are they oh no they're coming up they're
coming up and then uh when i saw the
actual video
it was actually like almost like two
seconds because it's one of those fast
paced you know those nike like
yeah shoot internet looks like they
probably have like 30 locations yeah so
the way they shot it or just
they they favored the subject of course
and then you just see the weight lifter
boom it was just like a split second do
you see the barbell brigade anything
in the back you got no benefit
whatsoever the rental fee
the rental fee oh nice that's pretty
good yeah that's great they paid you
for that one yeah oh wow that one was
like 10 g's i think
wow before not even using your place for
a second
they're stupid
for like a two-minute spot casey chan on
the record says nike's stupid
just do it you're stupid yeah it's
supposed to be off the record dude 10
g's dude 10 g's for for two seconds they
probably
fart that in like a millisecond bro true
you gotta think what do i know what do i
know what i mean they're like what if
they're like hey we should inspire small
business owners
let's give them 10 g's for one second oh
okay see they're [ __ ] so nice that
was pretty cool
now we're all talking about them like i
have a relationship with them
i think we got zero dollars for the
documentary because i think for us
for us what we really care about is
having like the best facility for our
members so
if it doesn't interfere with our
business we don't really charge
oh bart hates business does he hate
money he hates me so nike
is just a revolutionary so so nike
needed a lock down
the gym like no members come in for like
10 a.m to 10 p.m
yeah you got to buy it out but but like
documented oh it's going to come in and
shoot pre-code at times
ah just come on guys i'll give you 500.
i'll give you money i'm not going any
lower that's it i'm not going to learn
that's it he's like you got to feed your
crew i'll buy i'll buy lunch too
all right that's it though i'm done he's
like the mr beast of fitness
i wonder if like nike manipulates the
market they go i think every business
does some form of manipulation
like maybe it's not always harmful but i
think there's always some form like
think about advertisement is a form of
manipulation yeah
right like true that's true getting you
to feel
and associate happiness and pleasure
with
you can't have a meal without tapatio
right
and then you advertise it and you go man
this egg doesn't feel complete without
tapatio baby and then you [ __ ] buy it
at the store
i really can't eat eggs without
spiciness though yeah
because it's nothing there's some real
reason i had it with soy sauce yeah
and sriracha grew up like that and it's
really good it's very very good
fish sauce though that blew my mind yeah
i'm out
and for that reason i'm out is it
because stinky yeah i don't like fish
fishy tastes i don't i like he's not a
man of the ocean i don't like i like
fresh fish
like when it's cooked on my plate or
whatever he doesn't like rotted fish
i don't like the winter vaginas like
that i'm one of those rare guys
[Laughter]
he doesn't like savory vaginas yeah
mommy vagina you mommy
today's video is brought to you by human
which is
hvmn for health via modern nutrition
and i really like that because you know
everyone is trying to get
more fit they want to go why do i feel
so groggy
how come i don't sleep that good you
know people are trying to find ways to
improve their lifestyle
and there's a lot of different diets out
there and one of the most proven ones is
keto and even for those that aren't
running keto they just want to reduce
the amount of sugar that they're taking
hvmn is
a whole range of products to help you
achieve those goals
they got keto food bars yep they got
keto collagen powder
they got mct oil and a lot of the times
supplements to make it taste good they
put all sorts of like
weird sugars and whatever and it kind of
defeats the purpose
in my opinion because you know if you're
on a keto diet you don't want
sugar at all or you don't want all these
extra things especially if it's a
combination of you want
organic kind of ingredients
and not so much manufactured and
processed it's hard to find those
products
and for me i'm really happy that we work
together because i got a bunch of
keto bars and i was able to use them on
hikes and i can
you know it's pretty like grab-and-go
but also i don't feel
sick after i eat it because i can tell
the difference when i get like a protein
bar or whatever
that has a bunch of like fake stuff in
it versus like real organic foods
yeah and i can't really take away so
this is kind of good for me because they
have a lot of plant-based stuff too so
it all works out so yeah if you want to
give it a try go to
hvmn.com off record to get 10
off whatever you want on the site go
check that out hpmn.com
off the record to get 10 off that's a
rarity in some cultures you know what i
mean like
some people could only be so lucky to
have something i just know what that
tastes like already
a lot of shitake you know what else what
other notes would you say about umami
pube i don't know what mommy means what
is it what is it
mommy is a kind of uh flavor cause like
they're sweet
they're savory there's also umami and
it's like this it's like a mixture of
flavor
that's like straight word is dank how
yeah that's what everyone calls that's
more chlorine tasting yeah
more like a bleach flavor yeah you don't
want it i really love this topic of like
market manipulation okay like that
that's juicy to me right now
what else is going on in mockingbird
okay so here's here's i want to know how
to move
something here's a market manipulation
that they did in la right so like the
train companies
use there's to be hella trolleys here in
l.a because like
back in the day um when they were first
advertising people in the east coast to
come move to l.a it's like look at all
this land we got and
you know we have these trains that run
from la to freaking santa monica all the
way to pasadena
and those heli trains the automobile
industry
they bought up a lot of they created
fake train companies like trolley
companies right
they started buying up all these like uh
trains
and then what they did is they took them
off commission so that people would have
to buy cars and buses
and all that and so that's kind of like
manipulating the market where you kind
of
take out this ability to spend on
you know trains now you could you know
that's one form i guess there's
like so many different ways i'm just
trying to figure out what i can
manipulate
well would you like to manipulate the
the noodle
industry the noodles what we saw right
now in bitcoin is like
is is we we made we saw people freaking
out and they're like oh [ __ ]
the crash is happening right and so
everyone starts selling
i don't want to [ __ ] lose all the
money that i made or whatever
or i bought it high but i don't want to
lose that much money so i'm going to
start selling selling selling selling
and as it goes down people are buying
buying so in essence to assist with the
market manipulation
if a correction or crash like that
happens again we should get on social
media and be like
selling all of our bitcoin right now
there's people doing that that's what
they do the pump and dumps
yeah even though we're even though we're
really just buying when he goes yeah
they're buying yeah they're buying when
it drips
yeah that sucks he's smart [ __ ]
elon it doesn't take much that's the
thing because elon isn't the cause right
but he just
began the fear that ended up scaring
people out of the market and shakes
everybody out
but that's like you you could get in
trouble for that [ __ ] it's market
manipulation
yeah if you're elon you you get
investigated by the sec
a little a little slap on the wrist and
you're fine then he's like but i'm
taking you guys tomorrow so
okay back up yeah and also he's counting
on all these carbon subsidies and [ __ ]
like that for his business
which is what part i mean that's why
they call him the subsidized billionaire
because he's been heavily heavily
subsidized by government funds
his whole run-up that's brilliant i'm
inspired by when did you guys start
making face masks for ken just
2004 15.
oh so you guys are way ahead of the game
but there's the whole branding
coven stole the branding yeah yeah and
now we have no branding now we're just
asian again
no they manipulated the market because
they got this first and then corona came
out
yep yeah corona came because they
created face masks we did
[ __ ] tons of sales in mass when the
virus hit
the problem is we didn't ever expect the
demand to hit the high so we never were
able to provide the supply
and then supply chains during the virus
also like got disrupted as well so it
actually became like a
it was one of those like if only it's
like it's like if you knew a dip was
gonna happen you would save your money
yeah but because we didn't know the dip
was gonna happen we spent all our money
and then when the dead happened we can
do anything about it so it was actually
a really really weird time to like
constantly be sold out with like a still
a regular kind of moderate supply chain
you know
and what's crazy about that is our
graphic designer
in january already two three months
before
um like it was official he was like
i think you guys should make face masks
and i'm like wait what
why like doesn't make any sense he goes
because he already uh he does
a lot of the designing for pro
basketball
so he was like there's already licensing
deals with basketball
and face masks and they're gonna license
laker face masks
[ __ ] dallas maverick face masks all
that stuff it's already in the works
face mask is gonna be a mandate for sure
and i'm like
what the [ __ ] there's these things that
are just like behind the curtain
hey are you gonna make it a mandate yes
i am okay then i'm gonna have people
already manufacturing these things
way beforehand so they make it yeah they
make it a mandate and guess what
in march boom face mask you have to wear
it all the [ __ ] time and there's all
these companies that
are magically prepared with cloth masks
too that's the joke
yeah the magically prepared part is
actually a kind of like a
if any if there's anything in the last
couple years i began uh
becoming woke too is the idea that like
you know the naivety of like
or the ignorance of the the fact that
things like insider training or trading
or like knowledge of that kind of stuff
the magical stuff
that is so prevalent for every [ __ ]
rich corner of this world like
everybody has some sort of secret
insider or knowledge or understanding of
something it might not be as like direct
as like
buy this right now because you're not
having brunch with each other
hey president what are you gonna do i'm
gonna do this what are you gonna do big
company i'm gonna do this
okay shake hands thank you dude the
biggest most mortal enemies fist bump
each other on the senate floor
and we but we all and we all think that
they hate each other
it's so funny like we're like we're on
the right no we're on the left and then
they're all the [ __ ] same you know
and they're all working for the same
people like wait what camera's that oh
c-span nobody's watching the [ __ ]
that's where you see the most leaked
like everyone put your mask on right
after like i'm so
glad i'm done with that speech right
dude remember that video where the girl
with the chick comes up she's a
congresswoman and she comes up and she's
like gotta do a little political theater
i gotta put the mask on real quick
itself
you see it with fauci you see what a
bunch people yeah yeah i remember all
the videos that came out where they're
like
we're free we don't have to do this
anymore i bet you that [ __ ]
walked up to the camera and did this and
then they went like that the whole white
white house press corps as soon as like
you know president walks away
they're all ripping their masks off
being around each other and [ __ ] like
it's so funny you know the worst part is
too i've been watching a lot of cooking
shows
during the pandemic and now what they do
is they'll have cooking shows
with two people but they'll be in the
same room but socially distanced
and they're just cooking with each other
and it's like what the [ __ ] is the point
if you guys are on set for seven hours a
day you've already been tested
beyond call optics these days yeah
sharing food but then these with social
distant it's like
and it's just like hey just don't do
that just cook next to each other yeah i
[ __ ] hate the idea of optics
yeah [ __ ] haters but we have to
comply by it yeah right you know
something like
we were just talking about this earlier
right it's like i don't know if i got
the vaccination for example
because i wanted to be safe against
kovid or if i got it because i didn't
want to be
judged by my circle that i constantly
there's a lot of people that are like
doing it because of social pressure but
they're not sure if they want to do it
but yeah there's there's a lot of
reasons why optics
when i put on a cloth mask at a store i
know it doesn't do anything for me or
the person next to me
but i know it makes people
psychologically feel better n95 masks
work
but we don't get those because the
medical staff needs them more and i
agree with that
but the idea that a cloth mask stops
covet is [ __ ] hilarious
yeah you know what really stops kobit is
abstinence yep probably number one thing
very true is when you sit down in a
restaurant you take off that's
that's i love that you walk you you walk
into a restaurant
and then you go covered frieza let me
try some of this
yeah the waitress brings your plates
with their hands yeah like there's no
gloves on like it's uh i'm hella guilty
of that [ __ ] i walk in for
optics with my mask on the second i sit
down i'm like even the food's not there
yet i'm like
thank you fine are you supposed to wait
for the food to be there i don't [ __ ]
know oh
i take it off the moment i sit down you
[ __ ] you're a piece of [ __ ]
i wait three seconds oh damn you're a
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
you stupid [ __ ] ass wait four seconds
you're twenty-five percent up on them oh
true i'm only [ __ ] forced
but you haven't done it yet so i already
got you there's a restaurant i walked
into i didn't have a mask
you know it's like june now in some
places they don't even care so
uh i'm not june at the end of may so i
walk in and then they're like oh you i
can't serve you don't have a mask i'm
like okay cool so i go back to my car
and i put the mask on
and then i walk in and he gives me a
thumbs up and the minute i sit down
which is like right next to the door
like just two feet i took it off and
then it was just normal
he kicked you out right now he should
have kicked you out which
is rule of thumb yeah you just gotta
follow you just gotta follow rules
i don't understand what the science is
but if it makes everyone feel good let's
do it whatever you know i think that's
what sucks is that there's so much
different information yeah and we're
told one thing and then another thing
and then it's
from our own government you know and
then it's like who what do you believe
at that point it's so inconsistent
because they don't know either
who do you follow it's what i it's like
because i don't mind following the rules
and i don't mind it but
it's but it's also like they're learning
as they go you know which is part of it
that's part of like what the science is
right it's like
a couple months ago we thought this now
we think this now
but at the same time it's like people
like to take that
and run with it and that becomes their
new narrative without taking any
other new information yeah and it's like
what the [ __ ] are you doing because
ideas and
and like with research and everything
it's like it's ongoing right
so it's like oh that's what we thought
but then now it's been disproven
and that's fine because that's part of
it but if you're not willing to catch up
with the latest information
then get [ __ ] and if you are aren't
acknowledging the reality that we killed
the [ __ ] flu
there's no flu anymore then you're
asleep at the wheel bro
we we eradicated the [ __ ] the flu bro no
yeah for some reason there's a lot of
coved you know recording but the flu
come on no one's recording the flu and
you [ __ ] beat it nobody even threw a
party about it
yeah i'm throwing the party there was no
2020.
no social distancing come on over bart's
going to be cooking it's going to be
dope
called asana desire
you